joe wrote into spotify you guys heard
about what happened when he went to
spotify
did you guys hear about what happened
with spotify so rogan goes to spotify
okay this was last week kai keeps
reminding me hey he's leaving he's
leaving he's leaving
and he even showed me his new set which
is sick i don't know if you've seen his
new set rogan's new set
really cool new set if you want to put
it up and show it kind of yeah i like
i love his new set he's got uh obviously
it's here in austin isn't it
the new suppressed images let's see if
uh
images uh right there that's one that's
second
right there so that's kind of how
they're putting this set together it's
not over with yet obviously they have
the new one you can see i think on his
instagram post
but that's kind of what they're putting
together pretty cool what they're doing
that is austin
nice as big as i thought it would be
let's well it's really creative
it's creative television but go to the
go to the data that came back about his
podcast on spotify
so it's it came back the full list of
missing
episodes on spotify okay
owen smith a bunch of different names
alex jones is missing
okay you got uh um uh
gavin mcguinness is missing uh alex
johnson eddie bravo's missing milo
yiannopoulos is missing
another gavin mcginnis is missing
another milo is missing
christine did you see that that's right
that's right so adam
bravo adam sometimes talk about
conspiracy theories he's missing
dave asprey is missing you got a lot of
people that's missing you know
huh steve grier what's the what's the
theme here though
uh i i am hopeful
that rogan's attorneys when they did
this contract they did it in a way where
rogan was free
to keep all the things that he talks
about on because if they control him
i don't think rogan's the kind of guy
that's going to be okay with that i just
don't think it's going to work out with
rope but you cannot
put a tasmanian devil in a cage you
cannot do that with a guy like that
rogan's got opinions he's going to get
his opinions hurt i mean his deal was
100 million it's not like he wasn't
making a lot of money or he probably
could have made close to that did you
remember what bill simmons
from espn then he started the ringer you
know what he sold for
to spotify 200 million 200 million money
demands
but i think he had he had a network of
podcasts through the ringer so there was
multiple and he had a lot of people yeah
he made 200 million dollars one of the
most annoying guys in sports by the way
bill simmons
very annoying but he people really
though no no one's i didn't say he's not
brilliant why is he annoying
because what i mean by you know is not
from my end
sports people in sports get annoyed by
bill simmons because he says the most
random things okay and he sticks to it
and half the time he's wrong half the
time that's what i've realized with bill
simmons that's bill
yeah i guarantee that this was going to
happen but guess who else does that
charles barkley does that oh you know
the black house is lovable
sweet oh yeah did
you know bill started as the sports guy
in boston so he did a yahoo.com blog
right so he was the anti-media guy
because i was working in boston at the
time at fox and
he hated on on air tv people he was
always ripping us and just making fun of
us in his blog he had a cult like
following then he went to espn
you know people loved him for his
writing and then now he was ahead of the
game though i got to give him credit in
he understood what was going on with the
blah or with the the podcast and really
got it going at espn and then when he
started the ringer that was the main
part of their business i think
the print or the online version of the
articles is just you know to support it
but 200 mil but you know i guess you
need a deep dive to just see what
everybody was talking about here on
these
episodes with with rogue but there's
nothing he wouldn't know
going into this new deal with spotify
right the deal you know i'm a little
concerned about that because
i don't know about not keeping those on
those are some of the best ones he's
done
that the viewers were talking about you
you're going to take those off because
he's contra
they took off the one where joey diaz
says what he used to do with comedians
back in the days i don't know if you've
heard about that
female ladies say you'd come and do this
and you get 10 minutes to talk and
they took that one out the common theme
here is they took off the controversial
stuff this
isn't a left or right thing right you
got nick kroll on there who's a
liberal hollywood you know actor so you
know you've got
um jordan peterson i think they took off
as well joey diaz comedian i don't think
this is a political thing but i think
it's just a controversial thing they
don't want
well that's the whole thing though yeah
exactly but but that's the whole thing
so you can't create controversial
content on spotify
then is that what spotify's brand in
itself is sure you cannot just talk
about anything on spotify and they're
going to be forced now to answer this
question don't you think yeah
they have to have some sort of statement
i think they would what does it say on
the top right
rogan's podcast is moving exclusive
spotify after signing a 100 million
dollar deal and his fans are not happy
about what episodes are being left
behind during the transition just to be
clear we're not gonna see any
rogan on youtube moving forward only
short clips based on what kai's telling
still apparently on me but then it's
gonna be a segway but by the end of the
year
i heard december last december it goes
100 spotify